and then ran away a reward for the
suspect's capture is now up to 300
thousand dollars breaking overnight
there are new details about the apparent
poisoning of russian opposition leader
alexei navalny including video from his
hotel room just
after the attack his colleagues say
tests reveal
traces of a nerve agent on a water
bottle from that room
charlie dagetta has the latest
developments the video posted on
navalny's instagram account reports to
show members of his team
combing through his hotel room just one
hour after learning he'd fallen
gravely ill carefully collecting
anything that could provide
clues and at great risk they claim a
german lab
confirmed that traces of the highly
toxic novichok nerve agent were detected
on that water bottle found in the room
navalny fell violently ill on a flight
from siberia last month
it was later airlifted to berlin for
treatment it was originally thought the
novichok had been slipped into his tea
at the airport before the flight
never a likely scenario says chemical
weapons expert
hamish de breton gordon so putting on a
water bottle
would ensure that navalny
would poison himself because it is that
dangerous
absolutely um a single molecule of
novichok
should be enough to kill somebody
the kremlin has denied any involvement
in the poisoning
of president vladimir putin's fiercest
opponent
navalny posted the first picture sitting
up in bed with his wife and children
since emerging from a medically induced
coma
expressing his happiness at being able
to breathe on his own
all day visiting the uk
secretary of state mike pompeo said the
united states stands united in the
poisoning of navalny saying
any use of chemical weapons is
unacceptable under any circumstances
navalny's team says he has every
intention of returning
to russia gail all right charlie jagged
are reporting for us thank you
i'm so fascinated by this story number
one so glad that he's okay
when you hear that he wants to go back
to russia that scares me well he's been
he's been fearless inside russia for
quite some time he's taken enormous
risks
but how can he survive anthony going
back that's what i
that's persistent some people wondered
how he survived before i mean
yeah it's he's he is the fiercest critic
of vladimir putin